Here's an example of a very simple
anomaly detection approach.
First, it establishes
the normal statistical
runtime profile of a program.
For example, in terms of CPU
utilization, memory size, etc.
This can be accomplished by
running the program many times.
And at each time, record the values
of these measurements and
then compute the means and variance.
Once the profile or
detection model is built,
when the IDS observes that when
the program is run, it's measures
deviate from the means beyond
the allowed thresholds or the variance.
Meaning that the values are outside
of their normal ranges.
The ideas outputs an alert.
Again, the main drawback of
anomaly detection approach is that
you can produce relatively
high false positive rate
because an anomaly can just be a new or
observed normal activity.